if one's attention is positioned towards
the devices like this if their attention
is position this way towards the social
apps then their attention is not being
positioned the other way and the other
way can be creative endeavoring such as
music are writing sculpting business
execution invention you can go to nature
bathe in oceans or in forests you can go
spend time with your friends and family
asking them deep questions writing a
down of the complex perspectives that
exists on a specific issue so you can
learn how to carry more perspectives and
speak about that which is a thesis of
the book stealing fire by Steven Kotler
I can go off but the fact that it is
connecting the world fantastic there's a
lot of really good stuff to it but we
need to honestly talk about how it's
majorly sacrificing human creativity for
the instantaneous lottery system that
were that we're doing and also the
meaning in life that is lost its
economic opportunity cost and its
meaning cost it's costing us meaning in
life yeah yeah so that's how I feel
about this and I'm so obsessed about it
that it's one of the one of the like
twenty theses that I'm trying to crunch
into a but into a book and movie yeah
right now and and I'm and I'm being more
patient with it
Poe I used to be obsessively impatient
with it yeah and I learned to become
more patient with it yeah because it's
synthesizing information takes time it
does take time yeah
[Music]